[Music]
charlie in dallas hi charlie welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave thank you for taking my call
and uh dr john good luck on your book
launch thank you good man thank you
um so i've been listening to you on and
off for a few years
and i finally realized i cannot out earn
my spending and i really want to reduce
risk while income is good
and i want to do it fast and i think i
finally understand the gazelle intensity
feeling
um but i'm afraid my wife isn't quite um
feeling the same way
um i've kind of come up with a plan and
she's not 100 behind it um what's your
plan we owe 35
well we owe 35 000 in back taxes um from
as far back as 2015.
um i owe 14 7 this year
we owe 12 000 on both of our cars
12 000 each
and
i want to basically sell my car and
throw everything we have the taxes
um and i think that we can be done
actually in the next three to four
months how did you tell her this plan
well we started
uh about january is when i really got
serious and i kind of just you know but
take take take
dave back to the like you sat down how
did you announce this plan
i i've been asking her multiple times to
kind of sit down with me and help me
figure out how to
create more room in the budget
and then finally we did that and she got
behind it and now you know i i finally
kind of encouraged her i was like you
know i think you can
you have some really good ideas usually
when it comes to saving money and uh you
know you're you're really helpful in all
these ways and i think that we can just
get on the same page you know basically
listening to you guys that one i think
our relationship will get a lot better i
think that we'll really make some
headway here um i tried to try to
try to tell her that i really needed her
help
um and
you know from from my understanding or
the way i feel is i feel like she's just
a little bit worried and i don't know if
it has to do with
past family stuff with her family and
money or
how long y'all been married you're here
with money
seven years almost how many jobs have
you had while you were married
this one
how many plans how many different plans
have you come up with while you were
married
well and that is to be fair and it's
never been to pay off the debt you know
we make
we make enough money we we can do this
we can do that because i have a new idea
every 20 minutes
and my wife is always like you're
scheming and scamming again
and it sounds like you were getting that
speech yes
have you tried this this conversation
because you came at your wife with a
math problem and you came with her
at her with an algorithm if we do this
and this and this then here's the result
everything's great
and she's heard that before
another way to have this conversation is
to sit down one night over a meal and
hold her hands and say
i am terrified we're not safe
and i feel scared we owe the freaking
kgb 35 000. 35 grand we have two two
cars that we can't afford we have a
house that we can't afford we're not
getting tracked terrified we're not
getting traction
i'm afraid we're gonna be old and living
on social insecurity
if it's even there
that's a different conversation than
well honey
cue up the carnival music i got a new
one right that's a totally different
conversation
and i have been very excited about this
yes
um
hey you're talking to two guys who get
excited for a little i mean you know
it's a good thing but what it amounts to
is you have a set of information that
has informed your emotions that there's
hope
she doesn't have that information yet
and her hope button has not been pushed
yet because you've got a head start on
her you've been listening to the show
you've been listening to other people do
debt-free screams you've got you've got
a legitimate information that has you in
a different place than you than that
and and so you know i run into that
sometimes here in the business in
leadership sometimes somebody will come
in and sit down and they go okay here's
what we're going to do and this person
we have to this person here uh you know
they're not going to make it we're going
to let them go and i'm like
stop the train junior you know you got
to catch me up you've been working on
this for a month you gave me 35 seconds
so you got to spend a minute here
catching me up
to where i can join you in this or i'm
about to put a quash on your idea and so
i play the wife in that case in your
world but because i don't have the same
set of information or emotions that they
do from having dealt with this person
goofing off or whatever they've been
doing inside the business here that
they're trying to lead and so
if they catch me up with those emotions
i might get on board or i might have
another idea but we got to get her you
know so it's
number one we got to get her caught up
and just go i think it's a real good
thing to go listen
i don't have all this figured out and
i'm a wee bit excited about this because
for the first time i got some hope
and i was previously terrified and i'm
afraid if we don't do something that is
way different than what we've been doing
we're going to keep doing what we've
been doing and that's not going to work
and here's another
number two i've thrown a lot of hacks at
you over the last few years a lot of
schemes and ways to cut corners my plans
don't work i found the guys who playing
that does work for millions of people
would you be willing to do his plan with
me or would you be willing to look at
that plan in detail with me and see what
you think of it
that'd be okay too coming to her with
humility let her get caught up with um
that
uh yeah because
you know at least she didn't say i'm
gonna sell your car yeah
i knew that wasn't an option yeah but
you were gentle hey you were close
though because you were like you know
you got great ideas you would really
look good in a uniform if you're out
working
you got close man if you were a nurse
you would be making some money
it let her she'll get there she'll get
there when she looks in the eyes of a
man who says okay i've had all the
plants in the world i've tried
and this is me taking a knee and saying
my schemes didn't work but i think this
will work and it's not my plan it's not
my plan and i'm excited about it and
would you look at it with me we do it
with me yeah and um i tell you what
we're going to help you with this um
would you go through a couple of these
would you look through a couple of these
videos with me we're going to put you
into ramsey plus as a gift
and that'll put you into financial peace
university and give you access to the
every dollar plus budgeting system the
premium system and it's all very easy
when you do that but
it's kind of like um you hear some of
these debt-free screams they're like
how'd you get your spouse on board well
we went to uh we drove to florida and
had to listen to you your podcast all
the way to florida and so it's like oh
after that they were on board who knew
it's like
i'm trapped in the dadgum car
but it's but it's it's they were
listening to dave and these other
callers not you in one of your schemes
again right yeah just hearing somebody
pull up some debt-free screams on
youtube
and and watch them watch their body
language watch those people's
watch watch how light they feel how the
difference how the
position of their shoulders was
different oh so beautiful
so beautiful it's called hope
and it's real it's very real